le amiche
[Musica]
dispiace perché sembra che non lo odio i
re primis ma è quello mobile che mi
farebbe lanciare il telefono se non
costasse mille euro l'iphone 10 l'ho
pagato mille euro poi subito dopo è
uscito l'iphone 11 sono un genio
ovviamente averlo comprato appena uscito
l'iphone 11 proprio smart guy l'unico
che manca tra tutti quanti di aver
provato proprio anche solo un livello è
il buon edy che manca ancora il livello
1 allora non so effettivamente è di su
mobili per quanto perfetto perfetto ok
avevo già provato a fare questo livello
ma non ho mai finito niente ma perché
avevo provato ad approcciare il gioco ok
quindi ci sta che non abbia finito nulla
proviamo a giocare con e di oggi non so
ragazzi e perché mi ricordo che già
anche sono questo era impossibile quindi
vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa ora
che sono più bravi in ora che ho detto
la carta dai che ho detto la cag ataf
unisci mi ha detto che sono bravino
ammazzami come faccio essere vivo non lo
so va bene è strano perché in genere
quando dico che sono bravo che sono è
poi muoio subito non sono morto subito
anzi mi ha graziato gesù grazie
non succede molto spesso questa cosa
meno male ragazzi let's go
questo livello che questo video e
mettete mi piace subito cioè non sono
riuscito a vincere il primo livello
senza mai morire è pazzesca sta roba
vauro si è perso un pesce alla ricerca
di nemo
va bene con eddy lo devo trovare giacche
a mangiare un so dove dove sta andando
io traggo un pesce ma porco il demo
prevista nella tua boccia di vetro
maledetto schifoso vabbè povero pesce
non è colpa sono però porca vacca
ok senza gambe chissenefrega senza
colonna vertebrale invece potrebbe
essere un problema
vorrei provare a vederla perché nei
livelli normali di happy meals con eddy
faccio praticamente ormai solo i rock
swing ormai non so più cosa normale ma
facevo solo i rock singh voglio vedere
se in questo effettivamente trovo più in
difficoltà mi pare di sì perché comunque
sto gioco quando l'ho detto non è più
insomma è fregio di super meat boy o e
cat mario messi insieme cioè più il suo
vice è la rovina dell'essere umano io
l'ho detto sempre mi dà ragione a chi
non maschera detto in un tweet l'altro
iene dove vede trovato bene
la chiudo almo detto e l'ho detta dei
possiamo ridere e poi puoi uccidermi non
mi uccidi va bene
raga sono emozionato sono molto
emozionata ne va avanti
con trovato dopo essere finito quarto 6
grosso ma non è un pregio e un
tirannosauro c'è ma non ho capito vabbè
andiamo avanti ragazzi allora per adesso
2 su 2 non è male perché nell'ultimo
episodio avevo fatti solo tre e poi mi
son fermato quindi tre su cinque è
riuscito a fare qua voglio provare a
fare cinque su cinque
la partenza non è male ragazzi è la
partenza non è male vediamo se l'estate
perché è di comunque sono skillato io
sono anni che gioca sto gioco almeno un
po di bravura me la sono portata dietro
alla versione per pc almeno quella
ho detto la caga tanel momento non se lo
vivo che perfetto che bello sto liver mi
sembra anche carino livello di colori
quando mai è di forza forza che abbiamo
finalmente trovato da che parte non solo
che parte andare la carrozzeria dalle di
qua spero di sì era giusto sa che non lo
si sia mai occhio occhio occhio occhio
malaga 3 su 3 incredibile è la prima
volta che vinco tra i livelli di fila
così vai col culo oggi cinque livelli li
faccio almeno cinque almeno per
recuperare l'altra volta che sono
riuscito a fare le solite ho già
eguagliato un record dell'altra volta
sarà vivo dove vado
devo prendere il bottone al volo ma non
l'ho preso mai nella vita fa niente
riproviamoci praticamente questo livello
dovevo schiacciare devo solo schiacciare
i bottoni poche parole non è male come
idea
il problema è che non li centro neanche
a pagarli però forse adesso sì buono lo
che culo va a destra la destra verso il
quarto o di odio verso il quarto livello
che smog hoc che devo saltare dire eh va
beh quando ci arriverò mai
e invece ma torno un fenomeno o se è
stata fortissima trovavo giacché forte
sono vivo mi ha tenuto in piedi il
manico non incastra sono ancora vivo
forse posso andare anche di quart non
devo andare di qua mi sa però se mi
salto se devo stare zitto dai dai che
questo ce l'abbiamo fatta dai dyer e
l'emozione di averne fatti tre di fila
questo è il quarto e l'emozione ragazzi
ce la faccio qui fuori ormai lo so
ormai lo so ma il piano perfetto
perfetto proprio lui maestro di happy
meals ok se ti becco se esistessero le
scuole di hoepli se sarà il miliardario
il problema è che non esistono purtroppo
e chissà perché mi faccio una domanda ma
non so rispondere molto bene
non è vero mai nella vita
allora porco il demonio porco il the
morning canning sono lanciato cela
qualcosa ma dove ma cosa succede mai
vabbè quarto l'abbiamo fatto vai verso
il quinto è così presenta malissimo il
quinto va bene allora ragazzi per adesso
tutto bene prova lasciare
scherzavo andiamo avanti di qua perfetto
perfetto provato a lasciare ragazzi
perché non la sentivo detto magari se
vado veloce tavolo della pace
magari la prossima volta sto zitto però
madonna cosa schivato finale proprio ok
ragazzi qual è il problema perché vi
giuro che non so come fare corro però
anche correndo e proprio difficilissimo
ma totale però proviamoci
ce lo fa da madonna
oddio cos'è questo me ne frega niente
vai vai vai bene le varie verrai
perfetto sono arrivato di qua del
traguardo
ce l'ho fatto posto martino fatti 5 o
proviamo anche il sesto ma dai provo a
fare anche il sesto rai non lo so e non
vi prometto niente ma già che ne abbiamo
fatti 5 very nice
oddio ragazzi tutto bene mi sa che muoio
ciao l'altro quando muori lui tifa a
partire proprio lo slow motion in
automatico c'è proprio automatico
dall'attentato dei morirete lo metto
vabbè vabbè ho capito
ok ok ce lo fa non so come ho fatto a
perché alla fine mi sembra aver fatto
con la prima per ok va bene cosa devo
fare qui che ansia
ok come prima minchia a posto a posto a
posto tutto ok tutto bene quel che
finisce bene non tornare a sinistra va
benissimo e uno slalom praticamente
perfetto damien traguardo da mentre
guardo eccolo lì
ho capito cosa vuole farmi fare pensavo
crollasse tutto il detto che dove scende
devi uscire a sinistra
ma non ho toccato tre volte dai fa
niente va bene oggi perché oggi
meraviglioso tra noi perché non capiti
aspetto ultima volta per fare cinque
livelli già messo non non ho neanche
fatti 5 non fatti tre tenori ci vogliono
fatti 6 posto gioco è tutto strano però
che video vi sia piaciuto adesso abbiamo
giocato in tutti i personaggi sul
turismo mai quindi dei prossimi episodi
faremo un po di mix spero che vi sia
piaciuto iscritti al canale aspettiamo
che esca è più visto e poi moriamo
definitivamente lasciato un bel commento
su quello che pensate di questo video
tipo che faccio schifo non è vero non
videro gli chiede a creare girato un
video da ragazzi
[Musica]